hi Oh Congressman Jim Jordan Florida
congressman Matt Gaetz you know when you
look at the people that had mentioned in
his report page and struck and Bruce or
and McCabe we got all the central
figures in the insurance policy aspect
of this one has to wonder is this now
what end Christopher steel one has to
now wonder is that where this is leading
Jim Jordan yeah the first guy that Bruce
or talks to after he mitts meets with
Christopher steel is Andy McCabe he
calls him up a day or two later and then
meets with him and Lisa pates so all the
key people at the FBI knew what was
going on before they take the dossier to
the court they knew the ORS involvement
they knew who paid for the dossier and
they knew that the guy who wrote it
Christopher steel had told Bruce or that
he was desperate to stop Trump and we
don't believe they conveyed any of that
critical information to the FISA Court
when they went to get the warrant to spy
on the Trump campaign that's why this is
so important we get it and they knew
this all upfront right when it started
in late July early August that's why
this is so critical that this
information become public and that's the
point if you got if you got paid struck
or steel and McCabe you got the whole
insurance policy mat cake and it's
almost like you got the board of
directors of the beat of the deep state
together Shawn and you know I mean but
they all hate Trump that way but the one
thing in common they all hate Donald
Trump Andrew Weisman knew too as well
Shawn anyone gets the invisi right
because let me just add one thing
because or is hearing from Christopher
Steele over 770 contacts and not only
they talking about firewalls not wanting
to be exposed but also oh did you get my
stuff to the special counsel which we
now know what contact was Andrew
Weissman and Shawn to put a finer point
on what Jim had said it's not the
statements or words in these documents
that we're looking for
it's the omissions it's the information
that is not presented to the courts I
mean we caught the ORS red-handed you
got Bruce or shuttling information to
the FBI that was developed by his wife
and the money paying for it all came
from the DNC I mean the ORS are probably
the most dangerous power couple in
Washington since the Clintons were
running around this place and I think
that until we get the information about
what was presented to the FISA Court we
won't know the
full depths of the misconduct at the FBI
and Department of Justice to
inappropriately lie to a court and I
think that the penalties are just
starting to rack up well let's go to the
issue that we now know a grand jury is
impaneled Jim Jordan and then at the
issue of unredacted by the President and
declassifying by the president is do we
have any idea we know witnesses are
called
does that mean that everybody that was
involved and that phony fraudulent
Clinton bought and paid for dossier the
fraud on the court and information
withheld purposely more fraud on the
court is everybody that signed that now
in legal jeopardy perhaps what we'll see
what we do know is the FBI and the DOJ
had a sophisticated leaking project
going on Andrew McCabe lied about that
according to the Inspector General three
times under oath and faces a criminal
referral and as Eadie pointed out
there's now a grand journey jury been
impaneled on the Andrew McCabe issue so
this is what they did I believe they
leaked information to the press and then
they use the reports the press wrote to
buttress the false dossier to give it
legitimacy when it was a false document
that was the game that was being played
and we know that from Devon Nunez memo
that the Intelligence Committee put out
where they cite news reports to add
weight to the dossier it was all baloney
this circular game they played that's I
think that maybe the biggest concern
that we see all right last night we may
see members yeah we may see members of
the media caught up in that as well Sean
you'll remember there was a reference in
the inspector general's report to
members of the media inappropriately
giving gifts to people at the FBI to get
stories and gets hips that may have
facilitated the illegal leaks and I
think people could go to jail for it all
right great work we'll see if that
happens maybe years early as this
weekend or early next week good to see
you both